bootleg cat podcast man representing
Harlem we got Nick bucks in the building
yeah we in the show what's going on okay
man we here what are we doing go run up
the new single with two chains so now
let's do it go run up that neighborhood
Hove yes sir and let's get right to it
man
yeah
I'm gonna call him in this [ __ ]
neighborhood
try the cab man I couldn't wait to get
with you boy yes sir yeah
look
yeah look been through the hardest at
times
but my [ __ ] didn't know what's up with
me catch me no dropping no dimes yeah I
was like seven I seen a fan shoot up his
own yeah I used to dream of this rapping
[ __ ] look at me taking it far yeah they
said it was up with my dog so I'm fully
involved
so many tears that got killed in them
streets by the murders himself yeah try
to style the way but I still know what's
going on yeah I was the one on the block
with the packing the drugs on my rolling
on I couldn't get used to the money I
was broke but that [ __ ] wasn't funny I
was pop but I never was bummy hold them
[ __ ] they still used to love me I
wasn't having no motion yet and I wasn't
too focused yet trap with the mice and
I'm roaching stress too many times he
was close to death yeah look how you
smoking a hot pack [ __ ] you ain't like
that yeah blow the money get it right
right back yeah holy zippers on my
jacket like a mic Jack yeah I was the
one that they chose and they ain't like
that couldn't get used to the money that
[ __ ] wasn't coming in but I was
determined to give me some I'm on the
block with a Glock and the two for
chance like what Imma do with this money
they choking them bro I'm like [ __ ] I
spin it then and jump in the cool with
the dummies that unemployment money
slowed up on them now he back to
shooting for money all of my life been a
victim of fraud cause I was around all
these [ __ ] and most of these [ __ ]
weren't really my dog like what did you
do for the hood what did you give up
your gun for the cause man these [ __ ]
be frauds don't you go listen to [ __ ]
cause it's gonna be you only you and you
facing that judge put me a two in a
crush on I put me a bus I've been
spending my nights faded lately with the
wrong [ __ ] looking for love looking at
my youngest self frustrated I just
needed me a hug welfare check baby
started rapping [ __ ] got a little buzz
pocket rocket on me while I'm in the
club yeah black man in America yeah we
the scariest but look how we carry it we
keep on breaking them barriers yeah he
got booked into this time with no
tattling and I ain't too proud of the
cycle but that need acknowledgment yeah
yeah you already know
came in here killed it let's go Nick
thanks for having me at Nick bucks
everywhere anyway make sure y'all go
chop in man neighborhood magic up out
now featuring Two Chains new album on
the way yes sir come on hey you just
watched a crazy freestyle and we drop
one every week sometimes more than once
a week uh and they're always presented
by our family at LRG now I love LRG I'm
wearing look I'm gonna just show you the
new shorts I got from them check out
them shorts my boy you know what I'm
saying and got the plain black tea the
plain black lrgt you know what I mean
listen lrg's back they just dropped the
crazy Jason hoodie with Jadakiss that's
from like 2008 for Halloween [ __ ]
Flames go to the website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 percent off
that's a significant amount of money
you're going to be saving when you go to
lrg's website Christmas is coming save
30 off just by going to the website and
using the promo code bootleg L Dash R
g.com we'll see you next week with a
crazy freestyle